plus que sept jours pour s'imposer dans
la campagne à versailles ce dimanche
matin les militants politiques
s'affairent à tenter de convaincre les
passants les plus visibles sont les
supporters de françois fillon avec leurs
tee shirt bleu on accélère la sceller
les derniers jours donc des derniers
jours pour convaincre les indécis on a
eu une une campagne très très atypique
donc on a encore beaucoup d'électeurs
indécis
l'enjeu tout faire pour que les
électeurs de françois fillon se
mobilisent lors du premier tour dimanche
prochain
on voit bien que françois fillon est en
train de remonter on voit que il arrive
à mobiliser de manière très large et
quand je dis très large chez aussi bien
sur le terrain donc on voit aujourd'hui
au marché de versailles on est très très
nombreux à tracter pour lui et c'est ça
qui va fonctionner c'est ça qui va payer
c'est le travail de terrain tout aussi
enthousiaste les électeurs du parti
l'est républicain croit à la victoire de
leur candidat
les costumes et toutes les affaires de
filles on n'en a rien à faire fuyons
c'est le seul qui est capable de
redresser le pays
mais le discours n'est pas homogène ici
à versailles les candidats en bas de
l'échelle dans les sondages restent
séduisants pour une frange de la
population
je suis assez intéressé par les idées
des petits candidats
ils sont beaucoup plus près des réalités
que nos ténors politiques
un discours que tente de faire passer
les militants de françois asselineau un
des six candidats prévus sous la barre
des 5%
je pense que ça marche très bien on le
voit bien en ça marche très très bien
c'est sûr il y en a quelques-uns qui
s'interrogent ils se posent des
questions qui pourraient voter mais
savent pas y avait de plus en plus
intérêt pour françois séners en tous les
cas jamais la dernière semaine d'une
campagne présidentielle n'aura été aussi
incertaine et décisive